indeed the expected value for the score is equal to the trace of Sigma x * row now we don't necessarily learn what
this expected value is but if we average the scores we obtain over lots and lots of Trials we're pretty likely to get a
decent approximation to the this expected value by the law of large numbers and there are some well-known statistical bounds that we can throw at
this if we want to be more quantitative about that statement we do something similar with Sigma y on the second third of the
systems the only thing that changes here is that we use the plus I and minus I states which are igen vectors of Sigma
Y and similarly for Sigma Z for which the standard basis vectors are IG
vectors and then finally we can use the formula that's shown on the screen which tells us what the coefficients should be
if row is written as a linear combination of poly matricies and by substituting our approximations for these coefficients
and possibly adjusting them a little bit to make sure that we get a positive semi-definite Matrix we get an approximation to
row of course there are details that I haven't gone into such as the accuracy of the approximation and the degree of
confidence that we can hope to have in it but hopefully that gives you a big basic idea of one way that tomography can be performed on a
cubit it's also possible to do Cubit tomography using the touch or hedral measurement and in fact this turns out
to be quite simple and elegant at least in mathematical terms what we can do is to perform just
this one measurement alone on all of the independent copies of our unknown Quantum State and by using the
remarkable formula shown right here we can come up with an approximation of our state by estimating the trace of PK *
Row for each K by the fraction of times the corresponding measurement outcome appears again this only works because of
the perfect symmetries that we have among these four states and there are in fact some really fascinating unsolved problems that relate to generalizations
of this approach to larger systems and that's a good place to stop the lesson thank you for watching and I
hope that you will join me for the next lesson which is about purifications and Fidelity goodbye for now